132 era jeff is the best among all
national league pitchers
yeah max has been outstanding the guy
you want when you're trying to sweep the
yankees in a double header first career
star vs yankees aaron judge is back
hitting second that's on the ground
o'reilly austin's got it judge gets down
the line in good shape but not fast
enough two ground ball outs for mack
street i think that's always an
encouraging sign for max
this one's hit high in the air toward
left center voigt just missed it
it'll be ronald lacuna junior and freed
has another one two three top of the
first
as masahiro tanaka owen won on the year
makes his fifth start for the yankees
tonight yeah four starts two good ones
last two not so much
there's the 1-1
swanson lines one right up the middle
grab by estrada so there the shift took
a hit away he hit it right up the middle
and there was tyro right behind the bag
two-way
and it is cut out and missed so one two
three go the braves end of one game two
no to the second we go max freed on the
mound for atlanta trying to earn his
fifth victory of the season and max has
his sign here she comes swing and a miss
there's the fastball first strikeout for
free tonight it's just 3-2 and max just
blows it right by him upper part of the
zone at 93. one-two pitch
breaking ball strike three called
found his curveball in the top of the
second no runs one hit we go to the
bottom half warm here in atlanta the
ball is flying well let's hope it flies
for marcel here who leads off the second
is shot the other way an opposite field
single for ozuna good piece of hitting
with two strikes for marcel and the
braves have their first threat ozuna
leading off first with no one out pitch
hit on the ground to third should be two
go to second one on the first it's a
double play a 5-4-3 d-p
pitch swung on and popcorn was a good
fast blow right in on the hands the
shortstop tyler wade makes the catch
to end the
tyro on the year four for 16 a homer two
rbis there's a little tapper soft
contact right back to the mound and
that's easy pickings for max second
comebacker and the first out pitch
is hit towards short broke his bat
dansby fires across in time and max
freed has his second one two three
inning so duvall rolls out to third
austin reilly the batter riley digs in
and launches one toward right that's
hard hit judge cuts it off he's running
free and easy he's got a cannon for an
arm so riley takes the ball the other
way and settles for a long single with
one out ronald grounded out into the
shift his first time up and he hits with
two outs
lined in a right center field that's
down for a hit camargo is going to stop
at second judge charged it cleanly
and the braves with two hits in the
inning bring up dansby swanson with
camargo in scoring position in two outs
tanaka's 2-2 to swanson
and there's a ground ball to short
little fee flip to second for the force
and the inning is over aaron judge will
lead off the yanks here in the fourth
against max freed now the lefties 1-1
swung on and line to center field and it
drops in front of a cunha for a base hit
so a single by judge gives the yankees a
good start to their
fourth inning
sharply hit toward third riley to second
for one camargo to first it's a double
play voigt doubled up so runner in
scoring position for frazier who had a
big game against the braves in new york
high fly ball he got under it i think
duval going back to the warning track
the park is gonna hold it oh frazier
just missed on a 3-1 count and max freed
lives to tell the tale no score here's
freddie freeman against bossier tanaka
tanaka deals cod artemis
so freeman is struck out again
and there's one away we'll deal 0-1
on and line to left right there is
frasier and that's the end of the game
the yankees have the first real threat
of the game second and third nobody out
strike three call perfect pitch
estrada caught looking
and there's the first down so there is
one away they can still score run on and
out and here is wade
that's lofted the left field let's see
if he gets the run in duval makes the
catch tagging is and duhar
and the throw is late
so it's a sac fly for wade the yankees
are on the board they lead one nothing
as this one's a broken bat shot to short
dansby long throw good arm and freddy
dug it out
and that is going to
retire the side well masahiro tanaka now
has a one nothing lead remember seven
inning game in the double headers
swing and a miss
duval down on strikes two away
and tanaka deals a half swing at a
slider way off the plate he struck him
out strikeout number four for tanaka the
judge has one for two so far in the game
a fourth inning single and the off speed
pitch judge swung over the top and max
freed has four strikeouts what a
sequence that was they're going in
and
that was tipped and caught what a pitch
freddie freeman can turn the game around
with one swing
high fly ball hit well toward left
gardner on the run still going at the
wall it's gone
freddie freeman with an opposite field
home run and atlanta has taken the lead
mark malanson is on to try to nail it
down for max freed who is the pitcher of
record the yankees have the tying run
aboard
ground ball
shovel to second and the braves sweep
the doubleheader